est-ce qu'il y a de regrettage c'est que
des fois on vous fait on vous fait faire
des actions qui sont assimilables au
rôle des CRS le seul moyen c'est c'est
de gueuler dans la rue puisque on nous
écoute jamais autrement
ils sont méprisés il faut de l'ordre
mais généralité que ce soit pour le
service de la route tout je sais que moi
ils m'ont sauvé plusieurs fois ah si
vous avez une
un qu'est-ce que vous faites avec votre
bateau
vous manifestants de venir manifester
avec un bouquet de fleurs et moi je vous
aime et moi je vous assure que les
gardiens
de poser un problème qui est important
il y a qu'un seul moyen qui sont
vraiment efficace c'est de de le poser
en groupe et de l'opposer face à la
population je pense que actuellement les
agents sont en train de reconnaître que
c'est un moyen très important je ne me
prononce pas en tout cas tant que je les
vois discuter aimablement avec les
gauchistes je dis que mon dieu
il vaut mieux que les voir discuter qui
va se mettre